okay two people who are watching this
live stream this is one of our infinite
series of meetings about incremental
development of whorfin language and we
are talking about a variety of different
topics today let's start off oh wow that
was easy with a function that I was
thinking about we have framed and I was
thinking we might like a function called
circles as well who pointed out to me
earlier that it's not that easy yes it
certainly is not so if you replace
framed if you replace hello with grid of
identity matrix of I don't know 10 or so
so framed with a rounding radius has
never properly measured its frame
margins from the rounding pieces of the
frame so the I said I said something
like framed of graphics of disk for
example right right
yes with a rounding radius that the
graphic will escape the frame well
rectangle not disk right that's
beautiful um okay so okay all right
explain that to me right so the frame
margins are being computed from what
would be the flat sides of the frame
they're not being computed from the
rounded pieces of the frame so you might
think of this as a as just a bug in
frame margin support a framed by the way
I can see there's a box here and the
problem is that the box is an adequate
box but when you yeah I get I guess see
the problem yeah how related is this
problem to the problem we have a 3d
graphics of not going out not properly
shrink wrapping to the box size I don't
think it
at all isn't it the same conceptual
problem
[Music]
well the content me you might not want
the content of this to be rectangular so
for instance if you just had a bunch of
text in the first argument of this frame
which you want the first line of text to
be shorter than the second line because
the top of the circle is shorter than
the next etc do we have any mechanism
for doing that in other words you're
specifying an envelope for the knot
non-rectangular envelopes no okay
well seems to me what we should do with
this is put it in the function
repository right now with its bug
because it's already very useful you
know with the bug so to speak um yeah I
mean cuz then plenty of applications
where it's perfectly sufficient to just
circle a single number for example it's
a little weird that it isn't what would
happen if I always wanted it to be a
circle can I do that you can do that by
specifying your own image size to be the
same vertically as horizontally I don't
know that there's an automatic wait
there's an automatic setting for doing
that sorry right into the end no it's
gonna look stupid but I mean yeah I want
the circles around the numbers to all
look like the circles around ten even if
they have whitespace in them right in
order to do that you need to measure the
height of the content and then make the
frame set an image size for the frame
box to have that height and width that's
the only way to do it currently okay but
that's not that I mean isn't there a way
of measuring the size of text what is it
rasterize has a raster size second
argument okay so if I say rasterize that
okay and then what do I do when you take
the larger of those and you set the
frame box image size to be 17 17 okay so
I can say that I'm framed image size
blah blah blah mm-hmm well I mean maybe
I shouldn't do this right now but I mean
and know this could be essentially a
function that's only if you wanted a
circle a a you know you didn't want an
ellipse or an oval right I understand
that understand so it might want to be
an option for circled for example but I
think I mean would this work in this
case okay so let's do circle girl don't
mind paying the penalty of doing the
measuring yourself then yes it can work
well I mean it's a function repository
thing that's absolutely fine and dandy
um okay so you're saying it's this and
then it's saying framed of expert comma
that rounding radius is that correct I
think it needs to be scaled of one not
zero point five I think point five is
working have you tried it for a larger
expressions well okay so this says image
size arrow half half
okay so now you say circled of a hundred
whoops
you
well something went wrong
what does some yeah okay so we know what
went wrong is that image size wrong well
that was right at least okay look I
think that I think this is a useful
function um
I mean look it's just that's a useful
thing to be able to do to give you know
so as someone who's not participating
the function repository much does adding
this there prohibit us from adding a
proper system context version of it
obviously not
no absolutely not um I mean I think we
should I think we should plan on having
a system context version of this because
think it's obviously useful and it'll
have various options like whether it's
you know whether it's like this or
whether it's you know and probably by
default it should stay circular up to
some size until it becomes ridiculous to
be circular am I making sense sure you
have some maximum eccentricity exactly
um want it to be interpreted as the
contents right like we have four
highlighted where the French doesn't
know a frame doesn't do that I wouldn't
worry about that that's not the main
point it's perfectly okay for it to just
be circle just like it's framed um all
right so
something for you know if look if loo if
you can make a version of this if it's
if it's easy for you to make a version
that isn't totally silly that would be
very useful and at the beginning we can
just put it in the function repository
rmally and let me just store this pen um
hold on in my repositories collection
I'm going to make a note
um okay let's go online
okay so we don't need to look for the
rest of the meeting okay traffic Thank
You Lou bye
okay so the next topic is our it's the
addition of multiple new options in the
elevation data okay and the names are
tentative so we will discuss the names
of some of them because this is mostly
image oriented right now so some of the
names do not fit correctly so the first
one is your projection so until now the
elevation data always returned things in
a correct angle of projection which
means that they were distorted mostly if
they were very far from the equator
that's why we are using here Iceland yep
so that was the previous result and you
see those images are showing the
distorted equal rectangular result and
the correct result so now we can tell
the system choose the appropriate
projection which is Mercator in this
case and we'll show that new result
which is the appropriate one oh I'm a
little confused in the default case
every every pixel here represents I say
can't represent the same region on the
earth because it is a rectangular array
but obviously the earth is not right so
here we have recomputed the dimensions
of the result and we have interpolated
the original result so that we have a
proper array that went past to lisa 3d
or something like that click on
something non distorted I I'm a little
confused so this originally is with
respect to lat/long coordinates is that
correct
exactly okay right so so each pixel is
you know some angular measure it's
constant I don't know Stan what the
default should be though yes so we have
the attendance so we have the tension
between keeping backward compatibility
equity that would point towards a
rectangular also because the original
data is a correct number and now the new
more useful view
or things how slow is it to convert is
it slow aliasing artifacts well in fact
this is using our linear interpolation
rather than nearest neighbors which is
what we use in Geographics for speed so
it looks a bit better than but so it's
also bits slower but it's not bad I mean
my point is that for real projection
data that is very local doesn't matter
what projection it is well it does for
example in this case right
I mean if it's very local but it's very
much to the north it will be distorted
no I say I see and in fact it was always
distorted it's just that we were using
examples relatively close to the error
they quit yeah yeah it's funny I was I
was doing a bunch of examples when I was
in Brazil and I guess that those had the
feature that they were reasonably close
to the equator funny ok
they worked nicely all right so you're
saying we would default to Mercator that
right for example if we do automatic we
can get even Antarctica right
I see I see I see
ok so automatic means what the same as
we would use for geo the same as what we
would use for geo image or geo or
graphics
yes in your image we decided that the
default was Mercator because that's what
it's usually seen in other places but
and because we don't always have image
data Erik the poles but we offer data
for the ports here what do we what
happens I think I've done this before if
I say GOM edge of South Pole um why does
it just say Antarctica there
okay chill range let's say a thousand
now let's say 500 miles so I can approve
something reasonable is that gonna
presume pisar artifact yeah it's it's
it's Mercator and because we only have
up to some point and then the rest is
blank now try that that same input with
your graphics and your graphics disabled
to realize that it has to switch to a to
an Essene with a projection around the
pole I see right so now do their job
read lines goes to to automatic and then
we see the grid lines that's cool what
happens if I do Geo grid lines on here
they are not because this an image we
don't put anything on top of one things
really we could put the grid lines on
top of the image but then we would have
to return I know Janine rasterizing them
yeah that's stupid stupid
nevermind because the graphics is
basically to your image plus vector
stuff I think that's I would go okay
fine all right so basically you're
saying geo projection will follow the
chair of graphics I mean sorry geo
elevation data will follow the
Geographics conventions I tend to prefer
that because working in the
documentation for example because we in
most cases we want to show maps and yeah
that's fine
okay so geo image however if you wanted
to superimpose a geo Emma Giorgio
elevation data how will you make that
work with your image you can always
specify the projection one or you can
set your projection goes to automatic
try there in the Geo image your
projection goes to automatic
I mean I kind of feel that but yeah I
think that's have dating that's richer
and just what I mean
by the way surely we can get this for
just this one tile we won't have very
high resolution data but I think we
should make this work or are you saying
that geo image for other places will
look stupid as well no there is me okay
but let's look at Iceland so this is
going to be Mercator make a job doesn't
look that bad why is it taking so long
okay so now I face what to say geo
project geo projection are automatic
it's very going to be the same one
because in this case this is small
enough that it goes to Mercator if you
say you know aus then it jumps to no I
don't want to say us I want to say
something that's really northern now
let's try spell border that's also going
to be market it's not northern enough to
not be Mercator no it depends on the
size maybe Norway right safely low
resolution yes okay
that's surprisingly low resolution yes
yes I would have to investigate way into
this we can increase that
that's a bit too small perhaps but but
we do have satellite imagery okay what
happened that and wondering whether this
for some reason it's not it's not
switching to digital globe I think I
think it should at this point this is
the regime in which this should be
switching to digital low blow but also
why was it black with the wrong chill
projection see why is it black on the
giro projection something is screwy here
but in terms of I mean I have to say the
idea that geo image and geo elevation
data you know the idea that these are
going to be different seems very
problematic to me so that you can't
superimpose them I think if it's
efficient and doesn't lead to aliasing
artifacts being able to have geo image
you know have the same conventions about
your projection will be highly desirable
okay can explore that okay and I really
do think we surely can get one tile of
the earth viewed from the South Pole but
it's not one tile it's it's the tiles
corresponding to each soon you can can
you comment on that yes so something we
have been thinking something about was
to get for example dicing in let's say a
similar projection for south or
something like that but we still don't
have that saw so we will need also to
support a different projection the
server itself to have nice resolution
place for for these but even not look
look by the time somebody is trying to
get high-resolution pictures of a
particular snowdrift
tough luck but it's just kind of
embarrassing that you can't look at the
earth from the bottom so to speak I mean
I'm just suggesting a low res some low
res tiles around there
it's not the highest priority by any
means okay default prediction what I
think maybe it's could be problematic is
that for generation data sometimes what
we want is a data and not something to
do a map necessarily so we should think
about that awesome
yes I mean in yes we want the data in
such a way that the metric on the data
is such that you know the distance from
mountain peak to mountain peak is
correct right and how is that achieved
there's no projection that will achieve
that because unless we were to you know
have the base space for the GOP
elevation data to be part of a sphere
right insofar as if I'm not mistaken in
so far as the sort of the base space is
a rectangular thing we're never going to
get that precisely well for small
regions the Mercator projection will get
very close just you need to know the
scale but but the shapes of things will
be correct modulo some global rescaling
but the projection is never going to get
that correct
okay so right so you that's your
argument for why we should use Mercator
right okay so I'm sorry was there an
outstanding issues left here no I unless
Francisco complains a lot I think we
should change this to an automatic okay
all right let's keep going
background yes so this is something we
discussed in the past and you know the
idea is your image does that so there
are points that are not in the in the
world so we have the option background
to specify what it should be so now we
need basically the same thing I think it
should say missing out of projection or
something missing
not in projected region but it's not so
much well if we do that suddenly we are
going to unpack and then everything will
be super slow
there's an implementation issue well yes
but it's a fundamental thing I think
well I know but the the problem of
having missing in unpack data I mean can
we get indeterminate to work okay fine
but I mean that is a separate issue
which we need to address post 12 is how
to put missings into pact material yes
but but anyway it's very typical to have
some kind of not data or missing value
value for in elevation data so for
example your teeth also has a metadata
they have a no data value so they know
that anything any value is a hack the
correct answer is missing so we can put
in a hack if we want to but putting you
know I mean it's just a hack to do this
but it's sensing us background right in
images we say background and we'll put
some color there right okay so you want
a default background it's basically what
you're saying yes because imagine that
somebody is constructing a 3d model of
this think the only are the only correct
answer is zero not really because if
there is about symmetry probably they
will need something which is under some
basil right I understand that but any
number other than like zero okay okay
you want you want a number I'll give you
a number the number is the radius of the
earth
it's a consistent number it's big what
units is this thing in it meters I mean
typically orin orin feet typically we
give him oh yeah it's not too big a
number minus that number I mean it's
kind of crazy but at least there is no
possible at there I admit that that will
cause graphics to blow up right yes so
thank you let me tell was chosen because
it it's it's kind of it's what it's
deeper than the Marianas Trench how deep
is the Marianas Trench but then for
goodness sake don't choose something
that is less deep I mean if we're gonna
choose something like that I hate
fact that this is a number okay it
should be missing okay let us please not
choose something less steep than the
deepest feature um I hate this but I
mean you know if you insist why don't we
choose I don't know anything like this
is a hack I understand that but if if we
suddenly blow up these two tons of
machines no it won't work I get that at
the present time it won't work um it I
mean this is something we have to
remember for the future as soon as we
can do this all right what do you want
to do I'm fine with our wedding there
value of the radius of the body if I
think that may be completely correct no
actually most things so long as relief
plot has plot range to automatic it'll
probably be okay you get what I'm saying
sorry what was the value minus the
radius of the body
I think relief plotters I don't know
yeah I mean my concern is that if you
have means that you're assuming that it
all get clipped off by the automatic
correct pretty much yeah
in that case right so it depends on how
dense that value is in the data yeah
well yes that's true
I see because hearing the bone
projection is you know like a third look
release cortisol oh maybe that's wrong
look this is the hack what we're doing
is clearly a hack growl as I say I mean
we should make a note that and I don't
know Sushma maybe you can start
accumulating these things because we
know we need to do this for these packed
things we know we need a way to deal
with missing um you want me to pick a
value I don't know - 25 kilometers or
something I don't know
that's horrible I mean what's the
cheapest feature on Mars do you know the
tallest feature is Olympus Mons right
yes I don't know what the deepest
feature is let's go say I can suggest an
alternate hack that nobody will like
what's that I which point all the Heiser
complex numbers and it can still be
packed that's absurd
I said nobody was gonna like it
look I think zero is less ridiculous
than any of these other things yeah I'm
fine good sir and then you sirs will
have to choose zero let's use background
arrow zero and and do we keep background
which is always used for color so do we
introduce a background value sure what
is the background value for a sparse
array it's just an argument right yes I
think so they're correct since the
second sushma can you please report yet
again that in the version 12 build here
that there is a that this Ross is
looking wrong okay I see that okay is it
the thing on the right of its that
you're talking about or what no it's
just wrong see the raft it's it's those
two things are smooshed together they
should move okay
I mean the thing Francisco is suggesting
of - the men of a 2-byte integer no no
that's usually used in the den mothers
because they are really use a 2-byte
right for compacting the values so
that's the only way they have for for
having the no data point all right zero
elevation data should we call it
background or you know what kinds of
things do we have the like background
value or default value we have probably
have default value stuff that means
something different
um I I don't think we should usually
follow because if all sounds something
like that what do we have in other cases
where we where we have values that are
outside of I mean this is kind of what
we're doing for missing right so this is
um do we have a way of setting up
something that is a by the way that's
another bug to you to report that this
didn't pick up magnification inside here
Sushma I don't see it I don't understand
what you're saying
this area here did not pick up the
magnification in the notebook okay this
is the information yeah new information
behavior um there was a discussion about
something called missing value that's
for something different but
I mean this is really I mean this is
such a frigging hack the correct answer
is to you know look we could document
this I suppose right now with background
because it's gonna go away because we
were eventually just gonna use missing
not in projection region so I think we
should support it with background right
now and expect that that will be
deprecated soon okay yeah if we are
going to support all so many let's say
sources have also missing data itself in
the data so that will be better
also to support some kind of missing in
the packet arrives yes I agree
completely another question or
possibility is what happens if in the
case where we think you know we're gonna
have lots of missings we switched to a
sparse array
does that was it you saw it but but if
the thing was just full of missings if
it was dense with missings then a sparse
array will be a fine answer but not you
know probably not gonna have enough to
low enough density - yeah right just
supported by quantity or a quantity
array can contain a sparse array inside
and still be a quantity array
okay that's nice um I assume you've been
thinking about quantity right
interaction with around a bit yes that
let's not go that Sam okay all right
fine okay chill range Q Center
yes so these three are at least your
ranges you have requested certain facts
so yeah so now it was the three of them
work there great this is all rasterized
so the results look bit worse because
they are all rest rest so that they not
book is smaller okay so yes I Verde to
reverse arrow true here that's because
the convention in relief plot and the
convention of arrays are reversed
so that's frequently needed I see okay
using a ray plot for example does not
need that right relief
same way around as contour plot probably
yes I think so
and unless plot 3d so this variety also
needs a reverse there yeah every plot is
the exception and that it goes top to
bottom instead of bottom the top okay
okay so now we go to the two other
options which are difficult to name
because here the arrange your ink pad
energy center are referring to the
unpredicted coordinates so we have the
proper name for but now we also need to
control the results from the projected
coordinates and for example if you get I
understand that's why you're talking
about plot right right exactly
yeah but but here plot because we are
going to return our a doesn't sound good
so we were thinking or perhaps having
something called geo grid range and geo
grid range poly and we we would
propagate these options through all of
the geo framework for example oh wait
wait so you're saying say that I can so
don't we have some kind of data range
thing that we use in um yes but it's
only data range I don't think there is a
party in version of this and and this is
used as the origin of the transformation
so this is precisely the equivalent of
our gear range not the crotch range so
they use data range and plot range as we
use geo range and protract oh this is
the fault thing this is the data ranges
for I don't even know we I forgotten we
had this wow that's quite vulnerable um
okay
so what are you proposing yes to
eliminate this lot in relation
I was CST in the elite range while the
trio grid range because in the same way
that we have geo position as and
projected and geo grid position as
projected
I see and what units is geogrid range in
that's determined by the projection
whatever that's determined by there okay
so geogrid position I don't even know
how to I don't really know how to use
geogrid position just give here c'mon I
don't know prediction yes but then I see
that so those geogrid positions are
specific values specific to the
projection exactly
yeah then this is reasonable geogrid
range will give the values in the
geogrid position in the geogrid
coordinate system exactly
now geogrid padding yeah I think we have
to have the same thing cheer grid well
it's actually geogrid range padding
right right okay somewhat grotesque but
I think it's okay and I mean presumably
we can say we can have those functions
as you were I think saying in you know
just like we have geo range right we
should be able to have geo grid range
right exactly most of the functions take
into your range could also take these
and right now they are taking blood
range like if we have these new options
which are more G oriented we can switch
to these right but plot range is
incomprehensible because it's in it's in
units you know it's in units where you
don't even know what the units are right
right it's the time inside the
projection exit exactly okay yes the
final one is roster size which is what
happens if I want to specify the size of
the output matrix and again roster size
doesn't look correct and it has the
wrong orientation so notice that there
we say six hundred four hundred and we
get some back something 400 600 okay
well what other things are like this
were you're getting back and array
these function is a bit of a first case
in that sense and that's why this has a
happen and we were asking this morning
shadi and she said that there are no
functions so for controlling array sizes
as an option it's always as an as an
argument what's an example words where
it is an argument image resize you know
I'm trained remember so we have like
this you know these coordinate
generating functions that are sort of
like array but they're array is an
example also but I think that as we
generate for example this could also be
applied in the G or gravity model data
and humanity symbol data and future data
reporting functions right I mean the
basic point is these are data functions
that return arise right so and I don't
know which other ones we're going to end
up having that are of that type right we
will certainly have and and I think
something called a resize could be a
proper name for following the image size
it has three dimensions well I mean the
problem is that that is prescriptive of
as opposed to evaluative so to speak as
I want an array of that size
hmm unless we create another function to
do some kind of precise similar to image
resizer what does that mean will that do
so to interpolate the values to the size
you want well we don't want to do that
because that's that wants to happen on
the server side here I mean the only
thing I can imagine you're proposing
array size just sounds awfully general
for something that's just so freakin
specific that's also you know the fact
that we call it dimensions in the
function that computes it is kind of
weird
yes but image image dimensions is a
function not an option so dimensions
right dimensions is a fun exactly that's
why I think dimensions is not a good no
no I agree I agree I mean what this
really is is something more like an
interpolated array size or something
although I'm not sure that we want to
commit to interpolation
um and something more specifically to
output array size
yeah I mean I think that would be better
um I hate using the word output we can
put idea here if you think this should
be specific to this area hmm but but in
this case we'll be more a geogrid
because it's really the final project to
the state space so may greet sighs will
be better even better that's really a
refer come and we those are a your it
sighs what would that mean I mean cuz
it's a grid what would that mean yeah
could be confused with Geo briefs range
right okay what is this thing really
this thing is the array dimensions I'm
trying to think of other cases where
we're going to look okay provisionally I
guess array size is okay I just wish I
knew
I mean the problem is raster size but
for the fact it's the wrong way round
why is it the wrong way round anyway
well this has always been the case
between the image convention and every
convention but was the rest of the
raster limit the x-coordinate of the
raster which one is first X or Y it's
the number of because normally in
dimensions it's the number of rows and
then the number of columns right right
but the image stuff would be across and
then up so you mean it's columns and
then rows yes in India rate but they
mentions of the raster I think follow
image right so we rested I something we
get an image that has two dimensions
well you're sure that this happens this
way around that if I say raster size
here so do rasterize of some time
something and ask for the raster sighs
you know graphics of rectangle with an
aspect ratio or that should be reported
as a bug sushma please is a bad choice
because it's sort of square already you
know so just to a string of A's okay and
now as for
exercise or image dimensions even okay
you know and it's much wider than it is
tall
okay so what's happening here oh I see I
get you're saying ah buh buh buh bah
yeah because this is going to return our
a would be nicer to specify your a size
rather than Gustav sighs hmm I just
think the term array size is way too
general I'm fine with something like GRA
sighs I guess it's not my favorite I
guess we can do that and they're going
to be very we already have for example
geomagnetic model data and your gravity
model data can take this and report
different sizes what happens sorry
where's the resolution specified if I
want one mile resolution how do i
specify that so the distance between
each pixel so right now you can control
did you fools do range and their
dimensions the resolution somehow is
controlled by the zoom level so that's
implicit in that because one thing that
I could imagine being useful here is to
be able to say one mile one mile across
the whole image or be to know between
pixels that there are two things here
that are relevant I mean one would be to
say I want this size of array which by
the way I'm not gonna be able to get
perfectly it's gonna require
interpolation to get me that or two I
want you know something about so geo
zoom level
let's say it will be lovely to have a
sort of combined thing that could either
be the resolution and miles for example
or a pair that just gives you know so in
other words something like geo array
size would be both able to be you know
300 by 300 or actually well okay so that
this is this is story this is screwy I
agree this is screwy because there's
really two different things geo
resolution which would be one mile or
something which would be a useful thing
to have I mean in addition to geo zoom
level you know one can be set to
automatic while the other one if geo
resolution is set to ten feet
it's like show me an image at a
resolution of 10 feet or something yes
we could perhaps have that quantity in
the assumed level itself and so we do a
computation that in first what is the
zoom level you are referring to exactly
but I would think it would be better you
know geo zoom level is a very definite
somewhat hacky thing that sort of burnt
into the structure of the world at this
point so I think it'd be better to have
a thing called geo resolution which is
just which which from which the geo zoom
level can be determined if geo zoom
level is set to automatic what is Geo's
do zoom level is automatic for most well
functions right yes okay so if you then
set an explicit geo resolution then
which would normally default to
automatic but if you set an explicit geo
resolution it would go and do this but
then it would be two different way stuff
especially find the same information
exactly yes that is correct
so if we if we give both we just ignore
one I think we ignore the resolution we
just use the zoom level because the zoom
level is going to work better because
that's what the tiles are generated for
I think we should go with geo array size
and geo resolution
also now that you mentioned this year
resolution it could also be a nice it's
a repository function to have a way to
convert a distance into a zoom level yes
but that's sitting apart yeah right
please write it yeah I I think we want a
separate thing I don't think we want to
I think the zoom level I think we really
just want to say zoom level 13 or
something because I think people
understand what that is and I think the
set of people who understand resolution
is different from the set of people who
understand zoom level like that okay
okay and then G all right sighs my
favorite but there was another one that
we skipped in the previous subsection
which was a speculation it's not really
needed just to go a bit above yeah I
know I was avoiding it so it's not
really needed because we can specify the
plotter ange or the gear resize to give
the actions I think it's fine let's not
put aspect ratio and I think that's
confusing I think it's you know just
wait until we're dealing with non
spherical planets or non spherical
bodies in the solar system there is now
a bunch of new functions - okay I mean
these two - a few tries and knit and
then the discussion of the name of
subset map
um okay hold on let me just look at
something here
um so % form is working now is that
correct yes
something like no that's wrong that
because that period should not be there
what I know of course it should be there
no it shouldn't be yes look stupid it
looks stupid it's the same stupidity up
here what make exact numbers out of
approximate numbers it's not it's not an
exact number it's a percentage
it just looks stupid nobody's gonna use
this alright seven three four eight ten
should have decimals then it's fine
right okay and where do we figure that
out okay look look look see this this
has digits that it's not showing right
this is the same deal as with a round
and so we actually can control that by
an option setting I understand yes are
you telling me it's too difficult to
implement this or are you telling me
that it's an important heuristic because
nobody's gonna use this it's the same
thing up here that looks stupid 125
period percent looks stupid and people
will not use it so let me just see if I
have this correct the heuristic you
advocate is if it were to give a whole
number percentage then remove the point
that is what I'm saying yes that's what
I'm saying simple as that because let me
point out that let me show you something
I don't know what what's gonna happen if
I do this if I say 27 years will explode
one digit yeah that's a freakish sort of
bug okay fine butBut my point is that
you're going to pad with zeros in
percent form because you have to mm-hmm
and you know let me give you a better
example let's say
okay so there that's fine this is gonna
look stupid again yeah it's just looks
stupid
I mean people won't use this the whole
point is to be able to get a plot where
you mark off percentage points right
well you say range of them let's take a
look at what this looks like
range of zero to one and steps of 0.1 I
want to mark these in percentage points
okay it just looks stupid you know we
all know this looks stupid we don't even
need to discuss it I mean it's it's I
understand you know this is a thing for
formatting things so that people get
percentages make the change okay I do
not think it looks stupid but I will
make the change have you ever seen
anybody write 20 point percent really
well it's meant to say 20 point zero
percent if you want that precision
really exactly yes and
francisco's noting we never show this an
emotion alpha yeah because nobody wants
it right sorry um what happens if you
have a smaller range of numbers so like
zero two point one in steps of 0.01 or
something yeah I mean this is you know
that's exactly what we want one percent
two percent sorry I meant oh five
magnificent one point five percent
beautiful but two-point percent doesn't
make it in this sense isn't that it's
going to look okay look the alternative
which we don't want to do is to say 2.0
percent because we don't actually know
it's well okay this the right thing to
do I understand that there's
inconsistency here because look does
percent form have a second argument
yes yeah pretty sure what is it it's a
precision venue like number four what is
that background do it next to me okay
all right but so what does this doing
because I don't see anything happening
it's I think you should try that with
the first example could we could you try
to not be honest speakerphone or
something
speak of fun cuz always we shouldn't be
hearing all that background noise it we
closed our door it might still be the
office next door but but if your headset
it doesn't pick up from that distance
anyway never mind okay alright so what's
your point here you want to say do five
digit precision there yeah that's fine
so what I'm saying here is this should
don't you please put yourself on mute
I'll put you on mute but um the in the
case where you have that number like
like if I say percent form
of two for example it's presumably going
to give 2.0%
right well this depends on the patent
option so this is a padding of shown
that tells what do we use to pad and I
think the default here is blank who
could you see rose and then it would
show the zeros right which i think is
what we should do in this case much like
the around case so in other words comma
two will mean two digit precision that
you're showing right so right yes
so in the case of 0.5 that would sum
what's cruelly mean 0.5 0 right or is
that not correct I I think so we can
also use the notation precision comme
accuracy and they will control accuracy
well to my mind okay what I think we
need for this case right of percentages
is I think we need to know how many
digits do we show right so this would be
literally if it's zero we would be
showing zero point zero percent if it's
two digits together what I'm saying yes
yes we have to control accuracy I
understand I understand I'm not telling
you how to implement it I'm just saying
that I think in terms of result what we
need is we'd get 2.0 percent if it's two
digit browser shoot that's not right see
then we'll end up with 55 percent which
is two digit precision this is more
complicated what we're gonna want to say
okay so here's the deal
anything to the left of the decimal
point in the percent is is free so to
speak I think what we're gonna want is
um well
who wants a number that just says how
many digits to the right of the decimal
point do we have sir say because we know
the scale for percentages we don't
necessarily for other numbers but we do
for percentages I don't think we need to
reinvent the wheel here on that second
argument we can without too much fuss
make the change you're advocating to get
rid of the decimal point when there
would be nothing to the right of that no
but look the point that I'm dealing with
is what if you want kind of everything
to be consistently see what I'm saying
we want on the one hand okay what if I
want this case right where I say zero
point five percent and fifty five point
zero percent this can be controlled with
the second argument infinity comma one
so long as you can map that from forget
the infinity part I mean we just want
something where it's an easy to use
percent form thing we just say how many
digits to the right of the decimal point
okay so we would need to have to invent
a notation for that yes this this takes
it into a new realm of of headache very
close to a code freeze we're what we're
trying to do now is invent a different
notation from all the other number
forums which we can do yeah okay I think
that it's needed for this release is
that the decimal point has to disappear
for these things can do the next thing
that we need to do is to think through
what we actually want here okay and to
me I mean people want to use these to
label plots basically and the question
is what do they want right do they want
to specify now it could be that we
simply default the thing you know the
default action is is fine but people are
going to want to write 0.5% 2.0% I think
or maybe they want 0.5% and then just 2%
I'm not sure
properly we need to allow both yeah but
how do we specify that that's the point
well the accuracy we would need to
invent some new notation for the second
argument like put it in put a number in
a list what about just if the accuracy
respect to be one wouldn't that be the
right thing to force it to give 2.0 yes
but right now we have to write the pair
so right now you cannot give only an
accuracy it has to be a pair correct
it's immaculate see sure so we can say 5
comma 1 and it will work are you
explained sorry I wasn't okay look yeah
we're gonna have to wrap because I have
to get to another thing here but but um
just to talk about um map across is a
name that makes me scratch my head every
time I see it I do prefer surface ed mat
let's implement it as that having the
exception that a single list means a
look not a deep single position just is
something you requested
yes it's an exception with respect to
the other position specs but I think
it's okay for this case um all right
good all right I should go to my next
thing um oh I noticed some the
lifestream George pointing out that
there are high-res images of Antarctica
he thinks um yeah um okay all right
thanks guys um so it looks like we've
got some knitting and things which we
have to schedule in at some point
okay all right